it seemed that vinyl was yesterday's
news as CDs and more recently downloads
replaced the good old LP but now the
old-school format is making a comeback
as shown by an increase in record stores
like this one in Berlin still adding
here of [ __ ] I was really pleased when
this store opened it's a clear sign that
there's a market out there and people
are consciously looking for vinyl again
before style nah items 1 this record
manufacturer in a small north germantown
of d poets also takes customized orders
for different colored records it's run
by Hogan Oman and is one of the five
pressing plants left in Europe not to
mind two dead CD the arrival of CDs was
a big blow to the vinyl industry we
asked some business friends what they
reckoned they advised us to keep hold of
the machines if we could afford to use
the space to store them g viola product
so inspired get easy well don't come be
a talk and when the first love parade
was launched in the DJ's needed records
to scratch with we were among those they
got in touch with we thought wow maybe
this gig is back on and vinyl is back
and today touchwood we're doing quite
nicely time I would to tune in the 19th
century there were different ways for
recording sound but it was german
american inventor emile berliner who
made the big breakthrough in 1887 he
registered a patent for what he dubbed
the gramophone the early records were
made of shellac compound making them
very fragile the introduction of the
vinyl LP cemented the discs future the
new material was cheaper and more stable
enabled narrower grooves and improved
sound quality
records were originally sold in plain
paper sleeves but now the music industry
was discovering the potential of color
printed cover jackets they were an
effective marketing tool of course and
collectors pay huge sums for limited
editions Zack Tipton makes a small
fortune turning unwanted records into
frames for glasses Tipton is based in
Budapest Hungary but works for a global
clientele prices for his spectacles
start at 300 euros sometimes people get
really upset because of the cultural
damage hey you're destroying great music
and what about these artists and all
that but you'll people have to realize
that that just like books or anything
that society creates not every one of
them is going to be a masterpiece
culturally not every book is going to
become a classical piece same with vinyl
vinyl sales have been continually rising
in recent years although they comprise
just a small fraction of music sales
today now 20-somethings raised on
downloads are discovering the charm of
records your very first vinyl is a
hands-on experience to savour which can
hardly be said for your first mp3 file
papel en tweezers I prefer it because it
has such a nice sound quality it's a
superior experience to listening to
music on your computer plus it's
something tangible instead of everything
just being digital what's in the hunted
as a snitch olicity guitarist vinyl
might be enjoying a renaissance among
the younger generation but sales
worldwide in 2014 totaled only eight
million discs so it still remains a
niche product
you